allora mai beauty conferenza è un
welcome back più a nord episode of
rimasti i ragazzi nello scorso episodio
che stavo giocando con il padre di uk e
io direi di cambiare e andare sul nonno
ciak che ancora non l'ho pagato di
striscio ma mi sembra abbastanza utile
cambiare personaggio ogni episodio anche
se non ho finito tutti i livelli man
mano diventano sempre più difficile
vediamo quelli con uno ciak come sono
fatti allora andiamo
la partenza mi sembra tranquilla filata
ragazzi non so se il nonno ciak l'hanno
fatto difficile o meno penso di sì
ragazzi perché praticamente sempre un
rage game però non vedo la difficoltà è
che io non con la chat non non mi sembra
che sia tanto manipolabile come
personaggi non so quanto possano aver
fatto i livelli difficili poi magari
[Musica]
prendi per il culo
stavo dicendo credo che livelli non ciak
siano fattibili poi magari poi ma
evidentemente evidentemente mi sbaglio
nel senso non solo i pin difficile
contro bar non facciamo figure non mi
fare fare figure di merda ti frega e
allora dobbiamo li vuoi 20 euro ridotto
a cava cà morta soft e non lascia che il
più difficili tutti c'era era meglio
fare ed allora via via fuori dalle balle
ho lasciato una gamba indietro ma chi se
ne frega
devo andare indietro vero qua perché di
schiacciata fare perfetto era un
ascensore ragazzi gli ascensori vanno
presi non in testa ma vanno proprio ti
venisse vive dentro ricordate quello che
è utile mani avanti ciambella
ma cosa ma cosa ma la cia bene alla
vittoria che l'ha mai vista va bene zona
bambini perfette qualcosa mi dice che
sarà comunque pericoloso ma proviamoci
io riesco a morire artisti posti e la
cosa bella di nonno ciak che comunque
non c'è una cosa bella una mela o
dicendo che ci sono cose che puoi fare
con 1 cech che normalmente non puoi fare
ad esempio
volare perché concia che si aprirà la
giusta inclinazione tu puoi proprio
volare a meno che non abbiano messo dei
limiti alla mappa che se non superi un
certo punto non puoi fare allora in quel
caso nome però non lo so non sapendo
vediamo
per adesso ho fatto tutto sono uscito
dalla kidzone entriamo nella friends on
perfetto vedi che puoi volare vedi che
bol.it partiti passa tutto il livello
se io se tu sei bravo con nonno jacques
e capace che ti fai un sacco di ho
saltato tutto il livello perfetto perché
non lascia che proprio questo se tu
riesci a prendere la spinta giusta ti
salti un sacco di roba e io punto a
questo perché è l'unico modo di vincere
livelli di edy è più il mobile che è
troppo difficile prova a saltare tutto
qua sono stati bravi perché hanno messo
al chiuso alle volte non puoi saltare
perché arangio proprio quindi va bene ho
perso una gamba non fa niente dove sono
dove donare anche ai 18 non capita no
ciao ragazzi mi mancavate già un sacco
non è vero allora se riesco a passare di
qua ferito gravissimo ma sono veramente
bravo quanto ci manca al traguardo che
sto facendo un sacco
porca vacca osa un secondo me qua è dove
ci siamo e come ci passò di lì ma non ci
passo ma come a me mi sa che non dovevo
andare lì
ok bellissimo questo mica allora vado
vado in vado in orbita me ne sbatto
forse ne sono andato no no no no lo
aspettavo
[Musica]
vuoi dirmi che il traguardo era
veramente lì sotto io mi sono schiantato
contro le robe vabbè lasciamo perdere
diventato un frullatore umano il
traguardo era lì era cosa più semplice
del mondo ma porca vacca comunque vedete
con non l'ho già che credo che sia il
giocatore tra tutti come alberato di più
stavo scherzando faccio pagare lo
aspetto di parlare la smetto basta non
parliamone
dovrei smettere di massa effettivamente
dico solo cagate però vabbè se ci sono
livelli all'aperto diciamo che sono
molto più fattibili perché puoi fare tu
esaltarli tutti almeno è quello che
prova a fare ok non è vero sono stupido
o fatta ce l'ho fatta bellissimo piano è
di qua cosa che ai quali devo evitare
cosi va bene fin qua ci dovrei essere
molo detto quindi non ci sarò mai però
ci provo molto bene molto bene piano
piano bravo lo zio bravissimo dove vado
non lo vedo ho seguito tutto perfetto
very nice speriamo che il prossimo sia
all'aperto che sono un casini allora ho
mio figlio la fabbrica dei nonni salve
feste zero non è all'aperto per un test
questo veramente quindi poi c'è la morte
di toldo perfetto sono bravo
non ho più le gambe ti servono prova fa
niente superato il test deve passare ho
capito se siete chiuso
ok perfetto grazie non ho più le gambe
ma ne faccio a meno
anzi sono un peso in meno da portare
test due sono stato bravissimo test 3
aiuto aspetta aspetta aspetta come mi
cappotto riproviamo se allora qua la
facile
ok poi mi sono cappottato non si sa come
va bene test 3 cos'è questo a questo
girava bene test 4 dio che ve lo fa
rimango dentro questa mi sembra
abbastanza easy teoricamente anno mi
devo far schiacciata a un capito non è
così facile in realtà perché devi avere
il tempo giovane che con gli arcole capo
le altre cose che ho fatto in confronto
non è niente però test 5 questo non l'ho
capito devo fare
non è vero
non lo sapevo allora ci siamo di nuovo
ragazzi stavolta senza gambe ma chi se
ne frega però vedere se riesco ad andare
dall'altra parte easy senza fare
bordello
mamma mia che casino è poi arrivato alla
fine no alla fine questa cosa vuol dire
tre no no ti prego
oddio sono vivo sono vivo per miracolo
dato una testata clamorosa come fatto
essere vivo madonna ragazza sto facendo
per via testo 8 quanti testi ci sono
quanto manca ragazzi non lo rifaccio
tutto ci ho messo 65 ore
ti prego sì
sì va bene fammi solo vedere che cosa
sarebbe stato quello dopo
mamma mia cos'è sta roba beh un tronco
c'era è uno meraviglioso una mira finale
bellissimo cos'è sta roba
solo per curiosità ai ragazzi perché
voglio vedere cosa ci aspetta nei
prossimi episodi sono veramente un
curioso non puoi neanche saltare il
livello perché c'è il soffitto siamo in
una caverna figo o mio dio ha per me lo
faccio da yamato qua e ovviamente
fattore scusatemi sono un curioso
incredibile visto che voglio solo vedere
cosa ci aspetta nel prossimo faccio solo
un tentativo se riesco bene se non
riesco ma non penso dice di sé non
riesco fa niente nel prossimo lo
proviamo comunque figo sembrava
promettere bene di qua devo aspettare
cosa c'è l'ascensore a c'è stava quello
va bene candy pratt ma eccolo andare qua
mammamia questo schivato pazzesco per
essere un tentativo solo non è male
ragazzi è già attiva prove perfetto c'è
una boxe fight
oddio piegati bravo
bravissimo gravissimo
[Musica]